[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Julie has
chosen to do so and she's in Austin
Texas Julie what's going
on hello thank you so much for having me
how are you we're doing great we're
great glad you called Julie Rachel
already likes
you I can tell she's so nice she likes
your
attitude do what oh gosh I said I can
relate to you cuz you're a mom like me
um not fair I can't be a
mother I'm kidding oh they're amazing I
have um I have a primary question and
then I have um a few other questions as
well but my primary is I sell real
estate and so I'm I'm really good at
making a bunch of money really fast and
I'm not so great at keeping that
consistent so um the last three or four
years of my career I've been living on
Gross commission income and not net and
so I'm in trouble with the IRS um oh boy
and so I I owe the IRS
$150,000 holy
Ma on my home and I'm wondering if I
need to sell my
home um in order to take care of that um
this last summer we had a series of
unfortunate events in our family which
has never happened before and that was
multiple car accidents at different
times which depleted our savings account
our HSA and medical savings and so we're
really starting back at Baseline for
savings as well um and so I feel very
vulnerable just even calling today and
and and asking like where do I even
start um so thankfully um our our debt
is relatively low um and I have $60,000
coming in for income the next three
weeks um when these unfortunate events
happened in our world um Late July early
August the the like mail in the wall for
for us was my real estate income
everything that was in escro which was
about five
transactions like exploded they s out of
escrow for a variety of different
reasons and I didn't have any income
coming in um until just now this month
um so we were able to pay and cover all
the bare minimums we cut our budget in
half all the have toos I mean we got
down to Bare Bones um and proud of us
for doing that um my husband and I okay
what does he make we have three
teenagers uh he makes 84
okay and I sell about 10 million a year
which brings in grow about 300 um but
again it's not consistent and I think
that's I would say I'm more comfortable
saying 8
million so we talking anywhere between
two and two and 300K is fair correct for
the last few years
okay um has the IRS been in contact with
you like are they what are they
saying so um I don't know if this was
legit or not but I I had a company help
me get on a payment plan with the IRS
and I I can't locate them anymore I paid
them two or3 thousand to get me on a
payment plan and um I I'm just I'm so
embarrassed I'm it's okay I feel bad
yeah no no well when you're in a
vulnerable state like that and you're
desperate you kind of just make
decisions and usually in hindsight you
look back you're like oh wow my
desperation drove some of those unwise
decisions right but when you're in that
pinch you're like what's anything I can
do to help the situation so um that I
understand how you how that happens but
um okay so the little bit of debt that
we have left we've got 25,000 and credit
card partially a lot of that was put on
just so we could make it through these
last few months um
um car we've One car loan at $6,000 and
then student loan 15 and then that's it
okay okay well the great thing is Julie
you guys make great money um I would
move this IRS debt to the front I would
I would stay current on the student
loans and the car and the credit cards
but I would not be paying extra on
anything I would pay minimum payments on
all of those and I would put as much as
I could towards this IRS debt the IRS
debt is always kind of the red flag debt
when we hear people
um because they can garnish wages I mean
they're in it's insane right so like we
want them out of your life as soon as
possible it gets a fast pass to the
front of the line it does get a fast
pass to the terrible ride analogy for
Rachel thanks I appreciate that George
light in the mood um so the 60 so what I
would do Julie honestly because you're
amazing like you're an incredible at
what you do obviously the market isn't
necessarily on your side right now like
it's been probably in the last like
three years um so you're probably
feeling a little bit of that but if I
were you guys your husband makes great
money I would just say hey let's just
you've already cut your lifestyle in
half what's the Bare Bones we could live
on because if you guys could find a way
to live on 70 right that frees up 14,000
of his income all of your income and
together you guys could get this debt
out you know within a within I don't
know a year 13 months um if you guys
really really and if you hustle Julie if
you were like all right I am I'm laser
focus
um you know if you guys called me and
you were making 70 and that was it then
then there's there may be some really
big conversations we'd have to have but
I I don't know George you Chim but I
feel I'm going you're going to make 150
Grand in six months potentially
right yeah I really shifted um after
everything stopped I expanded the market
that I was in and just took anything
that was coming in and and it's the
fruit is here good yeah um so that's the
deal think about it this way in 6 months
you could have this IRS debt paid off
but here's the key that money from your
real estate doesn't even touch your life
it hits your bank account it goes right
to the IRS that's it that's what you
want me to do yes like put that as
primary every single scent you make from
Real Estate right now go to the IRS in 6
months the IRS debt is paid if you make
150 gross right now we still have to
worry about taxes for the future income
you're making but then we can knock out
your other debt you've got what
another 30 how much do you have total 25
six and 15 so you got 46 in consumer Deb
after the car first yeah so just knock
out smallest to largest balance from
there that's probably going to knocked
out three months later are you guys um
budgeting Julie at all you and your
husband oh yes um we have weekly budget
meetings now this is all new for us like
the last Yeah couple of months you know
do you guys use every dollar our
budgeting app I do I I do because it's a
daily going through our bank account
he's wired differently and likes the
spreadsheet okay okay no that's good um
I just want to make sure yeah that um
that you guys have some kind of plan
that you're doing that's going to be
helpful too um and it's going to be
uncomfortable Julie I mean I know you
already feel that with already cutting
the lifestyle down but um but you're a
high producer I mean you're you're
amazing of killing and doing so well
with your work so income wise I'm not
worried about you guys cuz you're
bringing in great income yeah a year
from now you you could be completely
free with an emergency F so I think the
thing is Julie it's it's now up to Julie
and your husband to like look at
yourselves and I'm sure you have just to
be like okay we're the problem like we
shouldn't be in this situation because
we make great money and so making sure
our taxes are done correctly is very
important and then making sure we live
within our lifestyle and when you do
that um it changes the game like you
guys will be able to actually enjoy your
money that you've worked really hard for
and you know you you you shouldn't have
to depend on credit cards to make ends
meet anymore you shouldn't have to you
know take out a car loan for a car like
no no more live in Lita Loca it's over
I'm sorry but here's what you do need to
do go get in touch with a Ramsey trusted
tax pro at ramsy solutions.com they can
help you navigate this you don't need to
get on a payment plan with some sketchy
company do they'll help you navigate
this but it's time and from now on
quarterly estimated payments that is how
you avoid the IRS down your back and how
you stay on top of this stuff for anyone
out there who's on that kind of
commission type job